there are days that define your story
beyond your life like the day they
arrived I'm Colonel GT Webb of Romney
intelligence pack your bags you're at
the top of everyone's list when it comes
to translations I already won what do
you want where are you from you'll be
reporting to me but you'll be working
with him when you're in the shell that's
what they call her the UFO
who's being carted off in the medevac
not everyone is wired for what you're
about to do so what it look like you'll
see soon enough every 18 hours a door
opens up that's where we go in
yeah the deceptive laminate I arrived
we need to see me
now that's a proper introduction have
landed around the world this is one of
12 we're never gonna be able to speak
their words please figure something up
it's their language
we need to make sure that they
understand the difference between a
weapon and a taught language is nasty
and sometimes one can be boss
you dreaming in their language it's
possible their prodding us to fight
among ourselves this is just the way to
force us to work together for once it's
more complicated how is it more
complicated Russia just executed one of
their own to keep their students got 21
hours of home base not global more so
how do we clarify their intentions I go
back in
well does this feel worse
everyone's when this one comes to
translations I already won what do they
want where are you from